as promised earlier the president's
decision about tariffs that we told you
about earlier comes just days before a
crucial congressional special election
right in the heart of steel country
Pennsylvania 18 of course vanamali line
is back in the Rust Belt tonight and
reports from Pittsburgh though
Pennsylvania steel workers went to the
White House to back president Trump's
new tariffs the United Steelworkers
union is not backing his choice for
congress state Rep rick ciccone as the
Republican candidate fights to fill a
vacant seat long held by the GOP in the
state's southwest corner the u.s. W
instead rallied for Democrat Connor Lam
this afternoon in a kickoff to the
weekend spinal get-out-the-vote push
Connor because he's for the working man
and is protecting Social Security and
Medicare and that's that's what we're
looking for this young Marine veteran
and former federal prosecutor has pulled
in support from carpenters to coal
miners and is endorsed by the
Pennsylvania afl-cio the largest
federation of labor unions in the state
longtime union ally and former VP Joe
Biden campaign with Lam earlier this
week while Kelly and Conway counselor to
the president stumped for Ciccone
billing him is the right choice for
workers I know Rick Ciccone also stands
firm and I know you all do with respect
to the people that motivated Donald
Trump to run for president in the first
place
the steel workers the coal miners the
manufacturers and all those employees
ciccone won the endorsement of the
National Federation of Independent
Business he has aligned himself with the
president's agenda from rolling back
regulations to new tariffs and tax cuts
and he touts his own long resume from
his Air Force service two years of
experience at diplomacy and
international business
and there's a stark contrast between
myself and my opponent he's on the
opposite side of all those issues so I'm
the man for this job I'm the man that's
qualified over 40 years of life
experience in in diplomacy in education
in the military in government in
international business
it's an unmatched resume compared
compared to part of the chameleon who
has almost no life experience this
election may test both the power of
organized labor and the influence of the
president president Trump tweeted today
that he looks forward to coming to
Pennsylvania tomorrow in support of
Ciccone and he expects a big crowd Brett
while I'm live in Pittsburgh Molly
thanks